I don't like having to swallow away
mosquitoes that are landing if you do
what I gotta say about that last episode
was won by Jordan flip Cup apparently is
the greatest game of all time so we're
back and this time we're here because
Colin and Ryan had an argument about
camping we're going to camp tonight do
some activities and listen to their
arguments in the morning
this is all great but we still have to
go to sleep here tonight you feelin okay
in there I will see if I wake up
morning guys gonna make some pancakes
this morning hopefully I don't get Ryan
out of bed so good morning we just
camped last night yeah there's also
something lurking around our tent
I'm not sure what the hell that was
there was nothing lurking around your
tent I know there's definitely footsteps
to decide who's going to get to share
their argument first we're gonna play a
game of spin the bottle I'm going to
spin it whoever it lands on gets to go
first
oh that's point Ryan it's just a B right
all right let's make this quick
I hate camping here's why
first off I love my free time so why
would I want to spend a free night
laying on the ground getting tagged by
mosquitoes cold and shivering in a
sleeping bag like a child at a slumber
party oh and not to mention the next
morning when I wake up in a pool of my
own sweat because the Sun decided it was
time for me to get up Ryan this these
are all arguments for you sucking at
camping look I get it
you want to embrace nature you know
living the elements whatever okay but if
that's the case why are you sleeping in
something that's so pathetically trying
to be a house I mean let's be honest a
house is like way better I mean it has
air conditioning I can shower sleep in a
nice comfy bed and when I wake up in the
middle of the night to take a pee I
don't have to worry about dying which by
the way any activity where you're trying
to not die half the time you're doing it
is not a good activity okay I understand
why are you gonna die when you take a
pee some crazy mountain man or some like
radioactive dude comes out and tries to
like stab me or just some dude with a
knife you've watched way too many moves
here's the thing there's limitless
possibilities that things that could
happen to me which also brings me to my
next point bears and yes I know that
bears are historically not that violent
towards humans but here's the thing
bears don't know that if you come
face-to-face with the bear are you
really gonna put your life on the line
because you think a bear is educated on
bear facts more than likely I think
you're gonna be home that is one of the
best moments I've seen why'd you spend a
few extra bucks in a place where you
could run into an eight-foot killing
machine
which reminds me camping is also
expensive as hell for no reason look I
don't think I need to say much more
we spent $20 on this campsite last night
if you like camping still great do you
just know that by loving camping you're
kind of setting us back a couple
centuries from an evolutionary
standpoint and that's fine
now if you'll excuse me I'm gonna take a
nap in my bed in air conditioning good
day sir [ __ ] yuppie man I am jealous
of my past self taking a nap kudos to
you Pastor Ryan you're doing it right I
think it's Colin's turn now we'll see
what Colin has to say all right what
were you [ __ ] the outfit is
ridiculous
so you don't like camping fine but I
find that offensive
saying you don't like camping is like
saying you don't like food or music or
stories it's just way too broad and
frankly it makes you sound kind of
stupid there's a thousand ways to sleep
under the stars and yes that's reason
number one that camping rules okay
obviously the proximity to nature thing
is great but that's just the tip of the
iceberg and yeah you can camp next to a
[ __ ] iceberg this guy did it in
Iceland you ever cooked dinner in the
woods it's great so much fun these guys
are happy let's not forget about
campfires you can drink whatever you
want you're not going anywhere
building campfires is great it's sitting
at campfires is great and s'mores people
have been sitting around campfires
telling stories since the dawn of time
why it's a lot of fun Ryan and even the
shittiest songs are fun to sing around a
campfire alright I call [ __ ] on that
one every camp I've ever been in in my
entire life there's always one dude in
the acoustic guitar and he sucks I'll
give him that that guy is annoying
you're right that guy's a pain in the
ass and if that guy's watching at home
you should be you know what you need for
a campfire wood look at this old dude
he's like a hundred years old and he's
still whacking away and then the embers
died down and you go to bed and you get
to wake up to the sunrise it's the best
feeling in the world and you know why it
rules because you get to go to the
swimming hole or a cave or the top of a
mountain tomorrow morning and hot
springs hot springs Ryan they're like
gods jacuzzis hey maybe you just want to
sit around camp and get deep with an old
friend that's fine you do you and here's
another thing this [ __ ] is cheap 25
bucks you can get a million dollar ocean
view check out this spot I was in last
weekend you don't have to be a
full-blown here not like me all you
really need is a sleeping bag a bag of
trail mix and a pair of sneakers a lot
of equipment if I went camping with just
those three things I'd be dead by next
morning everything else why did you have
to subject us to old man but then
outdoor sex is about the greatest thing
there is you can be as loud as you want
and there's literally no one around a
fury campsite is probably one of the
only places in the world where men
women could be as uncivilized as they
like and still get laid but I don't want
to get gross and dirty and covered in
bugs clamping is perfectly all right
who wouldn't want to sleep in a feather
bed in the wilderness this is total
[ __ ] here glamping does not count
maybe you just want to spend some time
alone and then you get the best thing
nature offers pure silence
but let's get real for a moment most of
us are going to go camping with our
friends and family and that's more than
just a shared hobby when you venture
into the wilderness with people you're
telling them that you truly deeply want
to enjoy their company and there aren't
very many places left where you can find
that kind of whiskey and let me ask you
something Ryan are you having fun right
now are you are ya oh really okay so to
sum up Ryan hates camping because it's
uncomfortable nature is too dangerous
and it's not fun and it's expensive
we're not in exactly the most glamorous
spot right here we're in the middle of
the desert who knows who's out here or
what's out here you're a lunatic it's
beautiful out here
on the other side of things Colin and
Joy's camping for many reasons mostly
that it connects you to those around you
nature is beautiful
it's inexpensive and it's a cool way to
spend your time and have sex and have
sex well spend your time have sex it's
all because you can't have sex at home I
think you both make very good points I'm
not gonna make a decision as to who wins
we're going to again leave it up to our
audience please vote let us know who you
think won and we'll let you know next
time humans evolved so they can live
better that's how we survive holy [ __ ]
see if I was Carter I would dig camping